.
Weindegustation im Barockschloss.
Zu Gast in Freudental ist einer der
reichsten Schweizer: Hermann Hess.
Mein Vermögen
beträgt etwa 250 Mio. Fr.
Der grösste Teil davon
ist investiert.
Durch die Zinspolitik
ist mein Vermögen angewachsen.
So geht es allen, die Immobilien,
Aktien oder Ähnliches besitzen.
Das Geld auf der Bank hingegen
wird nicht mehr, sondern weniger.
Wer hat, dem wird gegeben -
und wer spart, zahlt noch drauf.
Stimmt diese Gleichung?
Und wie steht die Schweiz
im internationalen Vergleich da?
Geht auch hier -
wie in vielen Industrieländern -
die Einkommens- und Vermögensschere
weiter auf?
Um diese Fragen zu beantworten,
haben wir
Immobilieninvestor Hermann Hess,
die alleinerziehende Mutter
Sonja Oberer
und die Arztfamilie Schneider-Riehle
mehr als ein Jahr lang begleitet.
Wir sprachen mit ihnen darüber,
worüber man sonst gerne schweigt:
übers Geld.
Ende Monat bleiben 500 Fr.
Wer bringt es
in der Schweiz zu Reichtum?
Und zahlt sich Leistung aus?
Expertinnen und Experten geben
Einblick in die neusten Erkenntnisse
und zeigen auf,
wie sich die Corona-Pandemie
auf die Schere
zwischen Arm und Reich auswirkt.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Herbst 2019 in Trübbach
im St. Galler Rheintal.
Hier lebt die alleinerziehende Mutter
Sonja Oberer.
Seit ihrer Trennung vor elf Jahren
ist sie
in grossen finanziellen Nöten.
Um über die Runden zu kommen,
hat sie gleich zwei Teilzeitjobs.
Mein Hauptlohn beträgt 2'500 Fr.
Dazu kommen Alimente von 1'473 Fr.
Nein, 1'479 Fr.
Durch das Putzen verdiene ich
ca. 200-300 Fr. im Monat.
Insgesamt komme ich
auf knapp 4'200 Fr.
Von diesen ca. 4'200 Fr. pro Monat
lebt ein Vierpersonenhaushalt,
drei Kinder und ich.
Kommen Sie damit gut durch?
- Nein, nicht gut.
Das ist sehr, sehr knapp.
Mir fehlt das Geld
nicht erst kurz vor dem Zahltag.
Ich habe schon viele Tage vorher
kein Geld mehr.
Wenn ich mal von mir behaupten kann,
dass ich mit dem Geld
einen Monat durchkomme,
dann habe ich schon viel erreicht.
Wie knapp ihr Budget ist, zeigt sich
im Alltag v.a. beim Einkaufen.
Sonja Oberer weiss genau, wo es
die preiswertesten Lebensmittel gibt:
beim Discounter im Nachbardorf.
Obwohl sie eine vierköpfige Familie
versorgen muss,
benutzt sie keinen Einkaufswagen.
Mit einem Einkaufskorb
oder einer Tragtasche
fällt es mir einfacher,
die Kosten im Griff zu haben.
Mit einem Einkaufswagen
würde ich zu viel einkaufen.
Das könnte ich
dann gar nicht bezahlen.
Dieses Hackfleisch kostet 4.75 Fr.
Ein anderes ist ein Sonderangebot,
kostet aber 4.99 Fr.
Ich vergleiche jeweils die Preise
und versuche, Geld zu sparen.
Sparen bedeutet,
dass es für etwas anderes reicht.
So.
Ich habe wieder
ein paar Sachen gefunden.
Ja, das kostet trotzdem.
Super.
Jetzt habe ich
wieder zu viel gekauft.
Die Augen waren wieder zu gross.
104.80 Fr.
Super,
jetzt habe ich trotzdem noch 100 Fr.
Heute zahle ich
mal wieder mit Karte.
Okay.- Gerne.
- Danke vielmals.- Danke.
Ich habe mehr ausgegeben,
als ich wollte,
aber ich konnte Esswaren kaufen,
die die Jungs sehr mögen.
Das ist auch notwendig und wichtig.
Wie lange muss das jetzt reichen?
Es reicht sicher für 2-3 Tage.
Ja. Doch, doch.
So lange sollte es reichen.
* Rasante klassische Klaviermusik *
Geldsorgen
gibt es in diesem Haus nicht.
Auch wenn Hermann Hess anfänglich
nicht in die Fussstapfen
seiner Vorfahren trat
und statt Unternehmer Pianist wurde.
* Gemächliche
klassische Klaviermusik *
Konsequent
und eigenverantwortlich zu arbeiten,
lernte ich v.a. in der Musik.
Man ist sehr
auf sich selbst zurückgeworfen -
und das Ergebnis
ist abhängig vom eigenen Können.
Laut dem Wirtschaftsmagazin "BILANZ"
gehört Hermann Hess
zu den 300 reichsten Schweizern.
Aber nicht
wegen seiner Fähigkeiten am Klavier.
Ende der 70er-Jahre übernahm er
das Textilunternehmen seiner Familie.
* Ruhige Klavierklänge *
Der finanzielle Reichtum
bringt mir natürlich Unabhängigkeit.
Ich muss mir nicht überlegen,
ob ich zweimal pro Woche
auswärts essen gehen kann
oder meine Ferien mit den Kindern
in einem Fünfsternehotel verbringe.
Ich muss mir darüber
keine Gedanken machen.
Ich kann spontan verreisen
oder auch mal ein Gemälde kaufen.
Seit der Scheidung lebt der zweifache
Vater alleine im Familiensitz,
einer Villa
im thurgauischen Amriswil
in der Nähe des Bodensees.
Statussymbole bedeuten mir
eigentlich sehr wenig.
Ich habe keine Autosammlung,
keine Rennpferde, keinen Privatjet.
Ich habe hier nicht mal einen Pool,
weil ich keinen will.
Ich schwimme im See.
Ich habe kein Boot auf dem Bodensee,
obwohl ich auf dem Bodensee viel
mit anderen Schiffen zu tun habe.
Sie haben kein Boot, dafür
eine ganze Schifffahrtsgesellschaft.
Ja, aber beruflich,
das ist ein anderes Thema.
2006 übernahm Hess
mit anderen Investoren
die marode
Bodensee-Schifffahrtsgesellschaft.
Heute ist er Hauptaktionär
und Verwaltungsratspräsident.
Mittlerweile schreibt das Unternehmen
schwarze Zahlen -
zumindest bis vor der Corona-Krise.
Die Übernahme
der Schifffahrtsgesellschaft
war eine Herzensangelegenheit.
Auch weil er als junger Unternehmer
Hunderte Mitarbeiter
entlassen musste.
Mit ein Grund war, dass ich mit dem
Ausstieg aus dem Bekleidungsgeschäft
sehr viele Arbeitsplätze
aufgehoben habe.
Deshalb hat es mich interessiert,
an einem Geschäft beteiligt zu sein,
das viele Menschen beschäftigt,
was hier der Fall ist.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Einen schönen Tag.
Auf Wiedersehen, Herr Hess.
Schönen Nachmittag, eine gute Reise.
Wie ungleich verteilt sind Einkommen
und Vermögen in der Schweiz?
Geht die Schere zwischen Arm
und Reich eher auf oder zu?
Mit diesen Fragen beschäftigt sich
die Wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin
Isabel Martinez.
Die Schere ging
in den letzten 20 Jahren auf.
V.a. die Reichsten legten zu.
Die höchsten Einkommen und Vermögen
wuchsen am meisten.
Die gute Nachricht ist,
dass die Armutsquote
relativ stabil blieb.
Es gibt von Jahr zu Jahr
Veränderungen,
aber sie ist relativ stabil und
im internationalen Vergleich tief.
Die Schere
öffnet sich also v.a. nach oben.
Wie ungleich der Reichtum
verteilt ist, zeigt sich,
wenn man die steuerbaren Vermögen,
also ohne Pensionskasse und 3. Säule,
auf einem A4-Blatt darstellt.
Wenn man hier unten die Leute
nach Vermögensgrösse aufreiht
und aufzeigt,
wie viel Vermögen diese haben,
dann haben die ärmsten Leute
kein Vermögen bzw. Schulden.
Dann steigt das Vermögen langsam an.
Ca. 80 % der Menschen haben weniger
als 250'000 Fr. Vermögen.
Dann ist der Anstieg
doch sehr schnell und sehr steil.
Zum reichsten Prozent gehört man,
wenn man als Person
mehr als 2,5 Mio. Fr. Vermögen hat.
Wenn man jetzt die 300 Reichsten,
die jährlich in der "BILANZ" por-
trätiert werden, aufzeigen möchte,
hätten die alle
keinen Platz auf diesem Blatt,
sondern würden
durch die Decke schiessen.
Hermann Hess
würde es mit seinen gut 250 Mio.
knapp über das Haus schaffen.
Der gut 600 Mio. schwere Tennisprofi
Roger Federer
immerhin auf die Höhe
des Basler Münsters
und die Ems-Chefin und Nationalrätin
Magdalena Martullo-Blocher
mit ihren ungefähr 3 Mrd. Fr.
auf die Höhe des Eiffelturms.
Die 2019 laut "BILANZ"
reichsten Schweizer aber -
die drei Söhne
des IKEA-Gründers Ingvar Kamprad -
würden mit ihren je gut 18 Mrd.
von der Höhe des Pilatus
auf das A4-Blatt mit den
restlichen 99 % hinunterschauen.
(Speaker) Fünf, vier,
drei, zwei, eins, null.
* Startschuss *
Das ist der Start zum Hauptlauf,
zum grossen Lauf über 10,6 km.
Die meisten Schweizer
befinden sich aber weder ganz unten,
noch ganz oben
in der Vermögensverteilung,
sondern in der Mitte.
Was für Auswirkungen
hat das Aufklappen der Schere
für die Mittelschicht?
Kommt noch vorwärts,
wer sich anstrengt?
(Kind) Maman, maman, maman!
Maman, maman, maman!
Familie Schneider-Riehle gehört
laut dem Bundesamt für Statistik
zur Mittelschicht.
Beide Elternteile sind Akademiker und
verdienen überdurchschnittlich gut.
Es ist Herbst 2019:
Stéphanie arbeitet als wissenschaft-
liche Mitarbeiterin beim Bund
und Rémi als Assistenzarzt
in einer Praxisgemeinschaft.
Mit ihren drei Kindern
leben Schneider-Riehles,
die ursprünglich aus Genf kommen,
in einer Mietwohnung
am Stadtrand von Bern.
Wir arbeiten beide 80 %.
Wir verdienen beide ca. 6'500 Fr.
Ende Monat
bleiben durchschnittlich 500 Fr.
Jedes Jahr
haben wir etwas mehr verdient.
Aber auch unsere Ausgaben
stiegen jedes Jahr.
Wir bekommen z.B. weniger
Unterstützung für die Kita,
haben drei Kinder,
und auch die Steuern steigen.
Wenn man mehr verdient,
hat man auch höhere Kosten.
C'est quoi comme lettre?
- Un M.
Wir sind nicht arm.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir
kein Geld haben und miserabel leben.
Nein, so ist es nicht.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein Stress.
Wir müssen jeden Monat schauen,
was finanziell möglich ist.
Das ist schon ...
nicht sehr angenehm.
Einer der grössten Budgetposten
für Familie Schneider-Riehle
ist die Fremdbetreuung der Kinder.
Die drei Tage Kita
verschlingen einen beträchtlichen
Teil der Haushaltsausgaben.
Finanzielle Unterstützung erhalten
sie als Gutverdienende keine.
Geht's euch gut?
- Ja.- Super.
Ihr könnt die Jacken hier aufhängen.
Hier in Bern
gibt es Betreuungsgutscheine.
Wir haben aber
keinen Anspruch mehr darauf,
weil wir zu viel verdienen.
Für den ganzen Monat,
für die drei Kinder,
bezahlen wir insgesamt 3'800 Fr.
60 % für drei Kinder.
Ist das ein grosser Budgetposten?
Ja,
das sind etwa 20 % unseres Budgets.
Ähnlich wie Schneider-Riehles geht es
vielen anderen Mittelstandsfamilien.
Auch wenn sie sich anstrengen
und das Einkommen steigt -
am Ende des Monats
bleibt trotzdem wenig übrig.
Zu diesem Ergebnis
kommen auch Studien,
an denen die Sozialwissenschaftlerin
Ursina Kuhn mitgearbeitet hat.
Sie und ihr Team
erstellen an der Universität Lausanne
das jährliche Haushaltspanel.
Seit 20 Jahren
befragen die Wissenschaftler
Herr und Frau Schweizer,
wie es um ihre Finanzen steht.
Das Lohnniveau in der Schweiz
ist tendenziell gestiegen,
das betrifft die schlecht bezahlten
und die gut bezahlten Jobs.
Aber das verfügbare Einkommen,
das Einkommen auf dem Konto
nach Abzug
der Steuern und der Krankenkasse,
ist seit 2013 stabil
oder sogar leicht gesunken.
Besonders von dieser Entwicklung
betroffen ist der Mittelstand.
Obwohl die Wirtschaft
vor der Corona-Krise brummte,
gestiegen sind die Einkommen
der meisten Werktätigen
nur unterdurchschnittlich.
Man kann nicht sagen,
dass der Mittelstand
vom Wirtschaftswachstum profitiert.
Beim Wohneigentum
sind die Preise extrem gestiegen.
Bei gleich bleibendem Einkommen
ist es schwieriger,
sich so etwas zu leisten,
als vor 20 Jahren.
Eine Eigentumswohnung
oder gar ein eigenes Haus.
Was früher ein untrügliches Zeichen
für Wohlstand war,
wird heute zunehmend auch
für Gutverdienende unerreichbar.
Rund um die Ballungszentren
der grossen Städte
sind die Preise für Wohneigentum
richtiggehend explodiert.
Oft zahlt man heute doppelt so viel
wie noch vor 20 Jahren.
Trotz der hohen Hauspreise
träumt auch Familie Schneider-Riehle
vom Eigenheim.
Maman, peux-tu me voir?
- Non, je ne te vois plus.
Tout en haut!
Non, regarde ce que tu fais.
Voilà, super.
Wir sind eigentlich zufrieden
mit dieser Wohnung.
Aber es fehlt uns
vielleicht noch ein Garten.
Oder ja, ehm ...
Und auch
ein bisschen mehr Unabhängigkeit.
Non, à 5 ou 6.
On va plus fort.
Eine Möglichkeit,
etwas zu kaufen oder ...
Das wäre für uns auch eine Lösung,
um unser Geld zu investieren.
Ja?
Wegen
der rekordtiefen Hypothekarzinsen
würden Schneider-Riehles
als Eigenheimbesitzer
wohl weniger Geld fürs Wohnen
ausgeben wie als Mieter.
Sie sehen sich deshalb im Quartier
Liegenschaften an,
die zum Verkauf ausgeschrieben sind.
Es ist schon etwas schwierig
in diesem Quartier.
In der Agglomeration einer Stadt
wird es immer schwieriger.
Und ... Und ... Ja.
Es ist ein sehr beliebtes Quartier
und ...
Anfangs dachten wir nicht,
dass es möglich wäre.
Oui, celui-là,
le jardin est très petit,
mais en faite le jardin
est derrière.
Tu vois? Là tu as un tout petit bout
de jardin, comme chez grand-maman,
devant il y a plein de plantes, et
puis derrière il y a le vrai jardin.
Tu vois?
Regarde, ça pourrait être
ta chambre! Tu vois, là?
Von steigenden Immobilienpreisen
profitieren v.a. Menschen
mit viel Kapital.
Menschen wie Hermann Hess.
Seine Firma kauft und vermietet
v.a. Geschäftsliegenschaften.
So wie hier im Zürcher Kreis 3,
wo die HESS INVESTMENT
die ehemalige Stadthalle,
die lange
als Autowerkstatt benutzt wurde,
in einen Bürokomplex umbauen lässt.
Natürlich haben ich noch
so eine super Zürcher Sparparkkarte.
Gut, also.
Jetzt sollte es herauskommen.
Die Gesamtinvestition
beträgt ungefähr 22 Mio.
Im Sommer 2019
ist der Umbau fast abgeschlossen.
Als ich das Gebäude erstmals betrat,
war es eine dunkle Höhle.
Alles voller Autos, voller Pneus.
Es war sehr laut,
denn es wurden Räder montiert.
Es wurde geschraubt und gearbeitet,
viel Lärm produziert.
Als mein CEO das Gebäude
zum ersten Mal sah, sagte er:
(Hochdeutsch)
"Ja, Hermann, was denkst du?"
"Was meinst du?"
Ich antwortete:
"Ich denke, wir sollte es kaufen."
Es gibt im Immobiliengeschäft
zwei Arten von Investoren:
Die einen sind Anleger.
Das sind Versicherungen
und Pensionskassen.
Jedes Jahr erhalten sie
einen Schwall von Geld
und fragen sich,
worin sie es investieren sollen.
Das tun wir nicht,
wir suchen nach Geschäften.
Und das ist ein Geschäft -
die Rechnung stimmt für uns.
Nicht aufgegangen
ist die Rechnung für alle,
die nicht von ihrem Kapital,
sondern von Arbeit leben.
Das bringt sogar
den Immobilieninvestor ins Grübeln.
Guten Tag, Herr Hess.
- Herr Vogel.
Herr Vogel ist wie ich aus Amriswil.
Nein, er arbeitet in Amriswil
bei der Firma METHABAU.
Wir lernten uns letzthin
auf der Baustelle kennen,
weil er gleich lange
in Amriswil arbeitet wie ich.
Was mit der Tiefzinspolitik
einhergeht,
das muss man ganz klar sagen,
ist Asset Inflation:
Immobilien und Aktien steigen -
und wer keine Immobilien
und Aktien hat, schaut in die Röhre.
Sie schauen nicht in die Röhre:
die 300 reichsten Schweizer,
die das Wirtschaftsmagazin "BILANZ"
alljährlich auflistet.
Asset Inflation bedeutet im Grunde:
Wer hat, dem wird gegeben.
Während Kleinsparer
praktisch keinen Zins mehr bekommen,
knacken Immobilienmarkt und Börse
Rekordmarke um Rekordmarke.
Deshalb haben die Reichsten
der Reichen auch die Finanzkrisen
der letzten Jahrzehnte
praktisch schadlos überstanden.
Weil die Reichen
viele Möglichkeiten haben,
die besten Kapitalanlage-
möglichkeiten zu kaufen,
finden sie immer Wege,
ihr Geld vernünftig zu streuen -
und irgendeine Anlageklasse
geht ja immer hoch.
Im Herbst 2019,
noch vor der Corona-Krise,
erschien die vorletzte "BILANZ"
mit den 300 Reichsten.
Das Resultat: schwindelerregend.
Dieses Mal haben wir
die 700-Mrd.-Marke geknackt.
Wir sind bei genau 702 Mrd.
für die 300 reichsten Schweizer.
Das ist absoluter Rekord.
702 Mrd. Fr.
D.h.,
die 300 Reichsten könnten gemeinsam
ungefähr 58 Gotthard-Basistunnel
berappen
oder 1'300-mal den Roche Tower bauen,
das grösste Gebäude der Schweiz.
Aber wie kommt man zu so viel Geld?
Wie schafft man es
ins Heft mit den 300 Reichsten?
Die Antwort ist simpel: mit Erben.
Eine Studie der Universität Bern
zeigt:
Das reichste Prozent
erbt überdurchschnittlich viel.
Das Kapital
bleibt sozusagen in der Familie.
Auch Hermann Hess
hat nicht bei null angefangen.
Im Keller der ehemaligen Textilfabrik
seiner Familie
hat er
eine Ahnengalerie eingerichtet.
1878 wurde die Firma gegründet.
Das ist mein Ururgrossvater.
Das sind meine Urgrosseltern.
Das ist mein Grossvater.
Dort hinten
sind mein Vater und meine Mutter.
Und irgendwann
gibt es dann auch ein Bild von mir.
Hier sieht man,
wie die Arbeitswelt damals war.
Also Kollektionen, Fabrikplanung ...
Hier sieht man die Zuschneiderei.
So sah es damals
in dieser Halle aus.
Die Shedhalle war sehr hell.
Die ehemalige Fabrikhalle ist heute
das Einkaufszentrum Amriville.
Und auch wenn Hess
den Umbau mitfinanziert hat
und am Shoppingcenter mitverdient,
etwas Wehmut bleibt trotzdem.
Ich erinnere mich noch sehr genau,
wie die Fabrik aussah.
Damals gab es kein Obergeschoss,
nur den Shedbau.
Ich war jeden Tag
in der Produktion,
manchmal in der Näherei,
manchmal im Zuschnitt,
manchmal in der Büglerei,
oft im Lager.
Ich mochte diese Branche,
ich fühlte mich wohl mit Mode,
mit den Läden, den Kollektionen.
Aber ich musste mich verabschieden
und stellte im ersten Moment fest,
dass mir der Beruf
abhandengekommen ist.
Das Geschäft mit der Mode
war längst nicht mehr rentabel,
als Hermann Hess und seine Schwestern
geerbt haben.
Als Firmeninhaber musste er
eine schwere Entscheidung treffen:
den Traditionsbetrieb schliessen
und alle Mitarbeiter entlassen.
Ich war damals
etwas älter als 40,
schwer enttäuscht von mir selber.
Das liessen mich auch alle spüren.
Aber ich hatte zum Glück
noch die Kraft,
um voll konzentriert
etwas Neues anzugehen.
Anfang der 90er-Jahre steigt
der Unternehmer auf Immobilien um.
Genau im richtigen Moment.
Heute hat er sein Erbe vervielfacht.
Wenn ich die Hess Investment AG
verkaufen würde,
hätte ich nichts mehr damit zu tun.
Aber der Punkt ist:
Wenn ich mit so viel Geld
in Zürich zur Bank gehen würde,
würden sie mir zu Immobilien raten -
und die habe ich ja schon.
Seit dem Umstieg auf Immobilien
hat sich das Geschäftsvermögen
verzehnfacht.
Deshalb sieht sich Hess
trotz Millionenerbe als Selfmademan.
Wenn ich den tiefsten Stand
in der Krise
mit heute vergleiche,
und den heutigen Stand
mit 100 % beziffere
und die neue Bewertung
als Berechnungsgrundlage nehme,
dann bin ich zu 90 % self-made,
zu 90 %.
Wie viel ist eigene Leistung und
wie gross der Einfluss der Herkunft?
Laut Soziologen der Universität Bern
hängt es wieder
zunehmend vom Startvorteil ab,
ob man es in der Schweiz
zu Reichtum bringt oder nicht.
Ganz klar: Von Chancengleichheit
kann keine Rede sein.
Man wird in gewisse Kontexte geboren
und hat unterschiedliche Chancen.
D.h., in was für eine Familie
man geboren wird,
bestimmt wieder zunehmend stärker,
was aus einem am Schluss wird.
Nirgends zeigt sich Ungleichheit
so deutlich wie bei der Bildung.
Kinder aus einkommensschwachen
Familien haben klar das Nachsehen.
Während knapp 90 %
der Kinder von Akademikern
einen Hochschulabschluss machen,
sind es bei Arbeiterkindern
nur knapp ein Viertel.
Auch bei Familie Oberer spielten
finanzielle Überlegungen eine Rolle,
als es um die Zukunft
des mittleren Sohnes Patrick ging.
Ich bestand die Aufnahmeprüfung
für die Kantonsschule
mit einer eher
höheren Durchschnittsnote.
Ich entschied mich dann aber
gegen die Kantonsschule.
Wenn man nie viel Geld hatte,
freut man sich vielleicht
auch eher auf eine Lehre,
wo man Geld verdienen und sich
selbst etwas finanzieren kann,
als andere,
die von ihren Eltern Geld erhalten
und sich schon in früheren Jahren
das eine oder andere leisten können.
Statt der Matura
macht Sonjas Zweitgeborener
nun eine Lehre zum Polymechaniker.
Hätte ich Geld,
wäre er jetzt an der Kantonsschule.
Ich fragte ihn, ob er sich
auch eine Lehre vorstellen könnte.
Er kann ja zum Glück beides,
er ist auch handwerklich begabt.
Er hat auch die BMS-Prüfung gemacht
und bestanden.
Er kann ja vier Jahre lang
diesen Weg so gehen.
Bist du schon da?
- Ja.- Super. Hallo.
Auch Philipp, Sonjas ältester Sohn,
macht eine Polymechanikerlehre.
Dann mach dich bereit.
Unten sind deine Sachen,
die Tasche ist hier.
Wie seine Brüder ist auch Philipp
ein talentierter Fussballer.
Kaum im Haus,
muss er gleich weiter zum Training.
Willst du noch einen Riegel,
den du auf dem Weg essen kannst?
Ja.
Ich gebe dir gleich zwei.
Wir wollten Kinder,
und ich wollte sie auch erziehen.
Das ist für mich das Grösste -
dafür lebe ich.
Ich gebe nicht auf,
ich möchte ihnen ermöglichen,
was eine normale Kindheit
beinhaltet.
Wir haben Salami und Schinken.
Ihr mögt ja Salami,
so könnt ihr euch bedienen.
Ich habe verschiedene Stellen
angefragt.
Die eine Stelle übernahm dann
einen Beitrag für die Jungs.
Auch die Kosten für Fussballschuhe
wurden nach dem Vorzeigen
einer Quittung schon übernommen.
Es gibt solche Institutionen -
nur kennt man die anfangs nicht.
Sonja bezieht keine Sozialhilfe.
Auch weil sie Besitzerin
der Haushälfte ist,
in der sie
mit ihren drei Söhnen lebt.
Meine Eltern haben uns unterstützt,
um in diesem Haus wohnen zu können.
Und jetzt haben sie
mich nochmals unterstützt,
damit wir bleiben können,
ich es finanzieren kann.
Ich weiss nicht, wie viel Mietzins
ich aufbringen müsste
für diese Vierzimmerwohnung.
Dank tiefen Hypothekarzinsen
gibt Sonja Oberer momentan
nur wenig fürs Wohnen aus.
Ein Segen
für das angespannte Haushaltsbudget.
Nur so, mit ihren zwei Teilzeitjobs
und dank Hilfe
von privaten Stiftungen,
kommt sie über die Runden.
Groll auf Reiche gibt es im Hause
Oberer trotzdem keinen. Im Gegenteil:
Roger Federer
ist eine Art Schutzheiliger.
Die Stiftung des Multimillionärs
zahlt einen Teil
der Sportschule des Jüngsten.
Und das Tennisass hat Fussballtalent
Christian sogar besucht.
Es ist ein sehr gutes Gefühl.
Du weisst: Jemand steht hinter dir,
jemand Grosses.
Er hilft dir und unterstützt dich.
Er ist und war bei Problemen
für uns da.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Gefühl.
Ungleichheit ist kein Problem,
wenn sie als fair betrachtet wird.
Aber wenn einer aus dem Mittelstand
stets hört,
dass die Wirtschaft wächst,
dass es der Wirtschaft gut geht,
aber gleichzeitig
das verfügbare Einkommen sinkt,
dann führt das zu Frustration ...
... Unzufriedenheit ...
... und vielleicht
auch Protestpotenzial.
Nach dem Abendessen
verlässt Sonja nochmals das Haus.
Zum Putzen.
So kann sie zu ihrem 40-%-Bürojob
in der katholischen Kirchgemeinde
noch ein paar Franken dazuverdienen.
Nach der Trennung von ihrem Mann
war Putzen für die Alleinerziehende
der beste Weg,
um schnell Geld zu verdienen.
Verglichen mit meiner Leistung
verdiente ich natürlich wenig.
Ich begann mit 16.50 Fr. pro Stunde,
und das ist natürlich nichts.
Unter 25 Fr. würde ich das
heute nicht mehr machen.
Denn Putzen ist wirklich
körperlich sehr anstrengend.
Am Anfang nimmt man alles
und ist froh um jeden Franken.
Ich konnte das gut
mit mir vereinbaren,
weil ich nach 1 1/2-2 Std.
wieder nach Hause gehen konnte
und so etwas Geld verdient hatte.
Neid auf jene, die Geld haben ...
Vielleicht haben die auch einen an-
strengenden Job, ich weiss es nicht.
Natürlich würde ich gerne
mehr Geld verdienen, klar.
So viel Geld,
dass es zum Überleben reicht,
dass es gut zum Überleben reicht,
dass wir mal
in die Ferien gehen könnten,
auswärts essen oder ins Kino -
denn das ist alles nicht möglich.
Auch Familie Schneider-Riehle
träumt von einer besseren Zukunft.
Ende Februar besichtigen sie
ein Haus in einem Berner Vorort.
Sollen die Kinder
die Schuhe ausziehen?
Ja, und die Erwachsenen
bitte Überschuhe tragen.
Okay.
- Merci.
Schon mehrmals haben sie sich
für ähnliche Häuser interessiert.
Jedes Mal wurden sie überboten.
Die Nachfrage ist gross
und treibt die Preise in die Höhe.
Guten Tag.
Verstehen Sie Hochdeutsch?
Ja.
- Ja.
Christoph,
kommen noch weitere Personen?
Es kommen vielleicht
noch zwei Parteien.
Noch kurz zum Ablauf:
Es geht an den Meistbietenden.
In der ersten Runde braucht es
noch keinen Finanzierungsnachweis.
Wir geben Ihnen nach
der ersten Runde eine Rückmeldung,
wie viele Parteien interessiert sind
und wie hoch das Höchstgebot ist.
Dann können Sie entscheiden,
ob Sie dabei bleiben
und zum zweiten Gebot
weitergehen wollen.
Es muss saniert werden
oder erneuert.
Ça va.
Obwohl das Haus aus den 50er-Jahren
gut erhalten ist,
sind noch kostspielige
Renovationsarbeiten nötig.
Trotzdem
ist die Liegenschaft sehr begehrt.
40-80 Parteien haben sich
für die Besichtigung angemeldet.
Das ist eine ziemlich hohe Zahl.
... für Kinder.
Der Richtwert bei der Ausschreibung
beträgt 1,3 Mio. Fr.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass er leicht steigen wird.
Er könnte noch um etwa 10 %
nach oben gehen.
Gut 1,5 Mio. Fr.
So viel wird das Haus am Ende
wohl kosten - ohne Renovation.
Ein stolzer Preis, selbst für
Gutverdienende wie Schneider-Riehles.
Tu as vu la cheminée?
- Oui, c'est cool.
Et la cheminée ... Je crois qu'il
y a une cheminée dehors, aussi.
Oui! Tu vois, tu peux aussi
faire du feu dehors.
Es kostet schon etwas mehr,
als wir uns vorgestellt hatten.
Aber wir werden schauen.
Wir müssen Häuser besichtigen,
um vielleicht etwas zu finden.
Es ist ein altes Haus.
Aber das Haus wurde gut gepflegt.
Ich habe auch ein gutes Gefühl.
Wir müssen mit der Bank
noch abklären, ob es möglich ist.
Manchmal eröffnen sich doch
gewisse Möglichkeiten.
C'est un coquillage blanc mais
il faut les ranger maintenant.
Je crois que le monsieur
de la maison veut qu'on sorte.
Kurz nachdem die junge Familie
das Haus besichtigt hat,
ruft der Bundesrat den Lockdown aus.
Die Schweiz kommt zum Stillstand.
Und auch Familie Schneider-Riehles
Traum vom Eigenheim platzt.
Die Preise sind derart gestiegen,
dass wir uns
dagegen entschieden haben.
Zudem habe ich ein gute Nachricht:
Ich bin wieder schwanger.
Unsere finanzielle Situation
hat sich nicht verändert.
Es funktioniert derzeit
nur alles etwas anders.
Der Lockdown
trifft v.a. die Wirtschaft.
Nichts funktioniert mehr,
alles kommt zum Erliegen.
Die Flotte der Bodensee-Schifffahrts-
gesellschaft bleibt im Hafen,
und viele Mieter
von Geschäftsliegenschaften,
die Hermann Hess gehören,
müssen schliessen.
Hier sind wir direkt konfrontiert
mit dieser Krise.
Unsere Kunden, Kleider-,
Schuhläden oder Restaurants,
haben zugemacht.
Zur Schifffahrtsgesellschaft
am Bodensee:
Unsere 110 Angestellten
sind in Kurzarbeit, arbeiten nicht.
Unser Umsatz ist gleich null.
Alles in allem
geht es hier bereits um Millionen.
Ein Land im Lockdown:
Viele bangen um ihren Job.
Eine schwierige Situation -
v.a. für alle,
die auch sonst
um jeden Franken kämpfen müssen.
Ich arbeite weiterhin im Pfarramt,
aber gehe momentan nicht putzen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es herauskommt,
das werde ich noch merken.
Aber ich habe
mit Sicherheit Einbussen.
Wie ich diese wettmachen soll,
weiss im Moment noch nicht.
Auch wenn es noch zu früh ist
für eine genaue Analyse,
die Corona-Krise lässt
die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich
wohl noch weiter aufklappen.
2020 und 2021 wird
die Einkommensschere eher aufgehen.
Denn was ist passiert?
V.a. Leute mit tiefen Einkommen
hatten Einkommenseinbussen.
Leute mit hohen Einkommen
arbeiten in Büros
und konnten fast umgehend
auf Homeoffice umstellen.
Sie hatten oft kein Problem,
weiterzuarbeiten.
Bei den Vermögen
dachte man im März noch,
als die Aktienkurse einbrachen,
dass es dort zu Verlusten kommt.
Aber die Aktienkurse
haben sich schnell erholt.
Der UBS zeigte in ihrem Report auf,
dass die Vermögendsten und Reichsten
der Welt sich erholt haben
und schon wieder Gewinne
einfahren konnten.
Superreiche scheinen immun zu sein
gegen die Corona-Krise.
Laut der "BILANZ" haben die
300 Reichsten während der Pandemie
rund 5 Mrd. dazuverdient
und besitzen nun
mit über 706 Mrd. Fr.
so viel wie noch nie.
Nach der letzten Finanzkrise
dauerte es drei Jahre,
bis der Vorjahrsstand
in etwa wieder erreicht wurde.
Jetzt haben sich die Börsen im März
innerhalb von vier Wochen erholt.
Das spiegelt sich in unserer Liste
und dem erzielten Rekord wider.
Kehrseite dieser Medaille
sind die langen Menschenschlangen,
die sich seit Beginn der Pandemie
überall dort bilden,
wo Hilfsorganisationen
Esswaren an Bedürftige verteilten.
Die Krise verschärft
bestehende Ungleichheiten
und zeigt vielleicht auch Aspekte
oder Gruppen unserer Gesellschaft,
die man vorher so nicht sah.
Wie z.B. Sans-Papiers
oder andere Menschen,
die in prekären
beruflichen Situationen sind.
Diese Menschen
trifft die Krise am meisten.
Lief es gut?- Ja.
- Super.
Geht's?
Bis hierhin. Ja, gut.
Okay. Super.
Trübbach Anfang November.
Sonja Oberer arbeitet als Freiwillige
für die Organisation
Tischlein deck dich,
die Lebensmittel
an Armutsbetroffene verteilt.
Es kommen definitiv
viel mehr Menschen bei uns vorbei,
auch wegen der Jobsituation,
die schon von uns gehört haben.
Wir sind doch schon
über drei Jahre hier.
Es kommen definitiv mehr Menschen.
Willst du ein paar? Du kannst
so viele haben, wie du willst.
Nicht zu viele.
- So viele?
Nein. Zwei, drei weniger.
- Sechs, sieben. Gut.
Wir haben hier Blumenkohl,
Broccoli oder Kohlrabi.
Aus diesen drei Kisten
kannst du dir drei Stück aussuchen.
Broccoli und Kohlrabi.
- Sehr gerne.
Willst du noch Randen oder Fenchel?
- Fenchel habe ich noch.
Ich helfe hier mit, weil ich
selbst mal in dieser Lage war,
in der ich darauf angewiesen war.
Manche fragten mich,
ob mir das nichts ausmache.
Ich antwortete:
"Nein, ich bin dankbar dafür."
Man zahlt 1 Fr. und kann auswählen,
was man gerade möchte.
Sonja selbst ist nicht mehr
auf Lebensmittelhilfe angewiesen,
und auch sonst
hat sie weniger Sorgen.
Einen schönen Nachmittag.
Sehr erfreulich ist,
dass wir eine Zusage erhalten haben.
Christian, mein Jüngster,
erhielt eine weitere Zusage
für eine Lehrstelle.
Er hatte bereits eine
und konnte auswählen.
Das macht mich natürlich sehr stolz.
Er lernt jetzt auch Polymechaniker
wie seine älteren Brüder,
sogar in derselben Firma wie sie.
Das macht mich wirklich sehr stolz.
Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Geh ran, geh ran!
Sonjas Situation hat sich in den
letzten Monaten sogar verbessert.
Mitten in der Pandemie nahm sie
einen dritten Job als Hauswartin an.
Trotz grosser Leistungsbereitschaft
kommen sie und ihre drei Jungs aber
noch immer nur knapp über die Runden.
Natürlich ist es nicht fair,
nicht in Ordnung.
Aber ich denke,
der liebe Gott da oben
schaut schon zu
und hilft auch etwas mit.
Sonst würde es mir ja
nicht so gut gehen.
Ich kann ja noch lachen,
obwohl ich Ende Monat
nicht viel Geld auf dem Konto habe.
Spiel! Schön, schön.
* Bedächtige Musik *
* Bellen *
Kann man noch
von einem fairen Spiel sprechen,
wenn sich die einen
von Monat zu Monat hangeln,
während andere
grosse Gewinne verbuchen?
Die Pandemie hat die Frage nach
der Verantwortung der Superreichen
für das Gemeinwohl neu gestellt.
Als guter Steuerzahler
leiste er genug,
findet Ex-Nationalrat Hermann Hess.
Die Wohlhabenden und Gutverdienenden
sind eine riesige Stütze
für die Gesellschaft,
denn sie werden zur Kasse gebeten.
Wir müssen nicht mal selber
eine Corona-Spende tätigen,
wir werden zu dieser Corona-Spende
sozusagen gezwungen.
Wegen der progressiven Bundessteuer
würden Wohlhabende
besonders belastet.
Zudem werde er
als Unternehmer und Privatperson
gleich mehrfach besteuert.
Mein Beitrag ist,
dass ich Leute anstelle
und auch bezahle.
Mit Sozialleistungen,
Altersvorsorge und allem.
Zudem tätigen wir
viele Investitionen.
Dadurch
werden weitere Leute angestellt
und das Leben weiterer Firmen
ermöglicht und unterstützt.
Das ist mein Beitrag.
Hermann Hess gehört nicht
zu den grossen Gewinnern der Krise.
V.a. die Schifffahrtsgesellschaft
ist wegen der Corona-Massnahmen
in Schieflage geraten.
Eigentlich
würde hier jetzt hart gearbeitet,
denn in einer Werft
arbeitet man im Winter.
Aber wir haben kein Geld mehr.
Irgendwann, wenn es so weitergeht,
werden die Eigentümer
und damit auch ich selber
schon zur Kasse gebeten.
* Ruhige Klänge,
Piepen von Wasservögeln *
Ca. 2-3 Mio. Fr. beträgt für mich
als Besitzer dieser Struktur
mein derzeitiger Corona-Schaden.
Als Privatperson
bin ich insofern nicht betroffen,
weil ich mich
nicht einschränken muss.
Aber ich bin insofern betroffen,
dass ich mir Sorgen mache
um die Mitarbeiter hier
und v.a. die Mitarbeiter
in der Schifffahrt.
Das ist schon belastend.
Denn davon betroffen
sind 110 Mitarbeiter.
Wir würden gerne mal Entwarnung
geben und ihnen sagen,
dass es wieder voll weitergeht.
Und das nimmt einen schon auch mit.
... faire des fotos si ...
- Hein?
Die Pandemie
löst grosse Unsicherheiten aus
und treibt den Immobilienmarkt
in neue Höhen.
Seit dem Frühling sind die Häuser-
preise nochmals kräftig gestiegen.
Das bekam auch
Familie Schneider-Riehle zu spüren
Aber sie hatten Glück.
In Kehrsatz,
etwas ausserhalb von Bern,
haben sie ein Haus
aus den 40er-Jahren gekauft.
Alors ça va être la cuisine
et la salle à manger.
Mais on va tout ouvrir,
comme ça il y aura de la place
pour tout le monde.
* Kinderlachen *
Für mich war es
eine emotionale Achterbahn.
Wir haben gesucht,
wir haben uns beworben -
und jetzt haben wir endlich
unser Haus gefunden.
Ich habe dich dann angerufen ...
Ich konnte es nicht fassen.
Ja, es war schwer zu glauben
nach so vielen Monaten ...
Nach drei Monaten oder so.
- Ja.
Poup!
Et voilà.
Merci.
Merci! Moi, j'ai de la bière.
- Moi, j'ai aussi de la bière.
Ce n'est pa de la bière,
c'est comme il faut.
Santé!
À la nouvelle maison.
Tchin.
Und wie viel
hat das am Ende gekostet?
Zu viel.
Ja, zu viel: 1 Mio. Fr.
Plus 2'000 Fr.
Ja, aber die 2'000 Fr.
kann man vernachlässigen.
Man weiss nie, ob man mal
von Armut betroffen sein wird.
Ich hoffe es einfach nicht.
Gemäss unserer Planung werden wir
wohl keine Probleme haben.
Aber man weiss nie,
wie sich das alles entwickelt.
Aber wenn die Zinsen
über mehrere Jahre tief bleiben,
wird es tragbar sein.
Wenn sie höher werden,
werden wir vielleicht
ein paar Probleme haben.
Aber wir wissen nicht,
wie lange es dauert,
bis die Zinsen wieder steigen.
Aber finanziell
würde ich jetzt sagen ...
Ich habe mehr Vertrauen
in die Zukunft.
Ich mache mir
eigentlich keine Sorgen.
Nach dem Umbau und dem Umzug
glaube ich nicht,
dass wir ein grosses Risiko tragen.
Natürlich besteht ein Risiko -
aber das ist im Leben immer so.
Das Risiko ist so klein ...
Für Schneider-Riehles endet das
Corona-Jahr mit einem Happy End.
Andere kämpfen derweil
mit grossen Ungewissheiten.
Ob Corona die Schere zwischen Arm
und Reich weiter aufklappen lässt,
hängt auch davon ab, wie sich
die Pandemie eindämmen lässt.
Und wie man für diejenigen sorgt,
die besonders betroffen sind.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2021